Getting rekt is quite possibly the worst thing
that can happen to you in a game of CS:GO.
Trust me on this one guys, it happens a
lot when I play.
I mean you guys know how it is, right?
You’re holding tight in ladder room, ready
to headshot anyone STUPID enough to challenge you,
and then Oskar flies down ladder with
an AWP and destroys you on the off-angle you
thought was perfect.
Feels bad.
(Casting)
Or all you want is your fifteen minutes of
fame, and well, this happens.
"I would like to thanks..."
I’m Colin for theScore esports, and this
week on Best of, we’re talking about the
best “get rekt” moments from CS:GO.
Now what does it mean to get wrecked or to
do the wrecking?
Well, it’s about hitting that perfect pixel
peak, it’s about nailing someone with a
dirty jump shot, or getting that double kill
collateral.
Just watch.
(Casting)
"Rekt."
"Gotcha b**ch."
(Casting)
You know guys, sometimes get rekt plays go the other way too.
You’re sneaking up behind someone ready to knife him in the back
and he turns around and kindly removes your head from your body.
(Casting)
"How embarrassing, how embarrassing."
"Aw man, poor kid."
(Casting)
Finally guys, we make it to my personal favourite part of the video,
you know getting rekt isn’t just confined to the virtual world. Sometimes you can get rekt IRL too.
"Thank you for asking me. First of all, I would like to congratulation for the enemy team, FaZe Clan."
"They worked really hard. It was a good feeling for us, and I would like to thanks-"
"I would like to thanks all of the people who supported with us, it was very wonderful."
"Well the stage has hit a set here. You know the two teams that walked up,
there is a bit of a spice in the step of both teams there."
"James and Dan looking fired up for this one."
"C’mon Chad don’t be like that you f**ing mug, c’mon."
"Wow! Wow, family show."
"He cheated, it was not a fair game and you know it."
"Mate, have you seen what you’ve done to me the last two weeks."
"Look, act like a b**ch get treated like one, that’s all I'm gonna say."
"Woah, Chad what are you going to say to this."
"Look mate it's the caches, we won the cricket."
"Cricket? Nobody understands Cricket. You gotta know what a crumpet is to understand cricket."
"I know you and your little croneys over there have been working on your strategies every single night."
"You know what I brought with me, an official letter from Carmac, we’re playing Dust 2!"
"We’re taking it all, your strategies are gone, you’re all f**ked."
"So you guys look nice and fresh today, clothes are obviously very well ironed. You’re looking stunning up there."
"Thank you very much Jason, and I see you found that shirt I threw out when I was ten."
"Yeah, I did."
"That one hurt a little bit."
"I’ve been told to get rid of you, so that’s
An An and Mo Mo to cast this one."
"I think if I continue to throw enough sh-t
against the wall with my predictions eventually
one will stick, and it feels like this Mousesports
one is gonna be..."
"So you’re going to throw four of the Na`Vi
members against the wall?"
Well guys, that’s all we’ve got for you
on Best of this week.
Now look, if your favourite get rekt clip
wasn’t in this compilation,
there's probably a good reason for that, but I know that’s not going to stop you from flaming us in the comments anyway.